Gentlemen, welcome to the Forge.
[Wil] On your anvils
in front of you
is a bar of high carbon steel,
from which you will forge
a signature blade.
However, as you may
have guessed, there's a twist.
You will also have to forge
your blades using these.
[cloth rustles]
These are all
random pieces of steel
from the urban environment.
We've got fire hydrants,
fire escape ladders,
subway grates,
road signs, pieces of railroad.
Each item can only be selected
by one contestant.
So choose wisely.
And in order
to keep things fair,
you will all be given
equal amounts
of the steel you choose.
Names were drawn from a hat.
Mareko, choose your item.
I'm gonna go with the sign.
David, go ahead and choose.
I choose the grate.
Josh, you're up.
Choose your item.
None of it's anything I
would ever use for a knife.
[Josh] So I'm feeling
pretty nervous.
I choose the stairs.
[Wil] The blade parameters
are as follows.
The length of the blade,
not including the tang,
must fall between 12
and 14 inches.
The overall length
of your weapon
must not exceed 22 inches.
Feeling a little anxious.
[David] This challenge
is gonna be tough.
I decided I'm gonna make
a long slender blade
that I really liken
to a bush knife.
What I'm gonna do is first take
the high carbon steel
and make it into a bar.
And then take two layers
on either side of the grate
and laminate it together.
[J] He's gotta be careful
blending those layers.
So he's got the high
carbon steel on the edge.
[David] This knife
is the first knife I've made
since I crashed.
I'm excited. I'm back.
Let's do this.
[Mareko] I'm gonna make
a chef's knife.
Kitchen knives typically have
a very thin edge.
So my plan was just
to forge the knife
in a way, so I had
a more robust edge,
which can withstand the impact
of hitting a hard antler.
I'm gonna forge
my high carbon bar
down into a flat stalk,
cut it up into a bunch
of pieces,
and then I'm gonna mix that in
with the street sign material
but only have
the street sign material
on the outer edges.
[fire roars]
[rock music plays]
[Josh] I'd like
to make a fighter.
I don't generally make them
12 inches long, though.
It starts to limit my design
capabilities at that length.
I wonder what's up his sleeve.
[Jason] His last name
is Smith, man.
He knows what he's doing.
[Josh] My game plan
with that stair material
is to draw it out, thin it out,
and get it on the outside
of my billet.
If that billet's a sandwich,
it's got everything
in the fridge, the pantry,
and something
from the garage in it.
[Wil] It looks like
Dave's dealing
with a little bit of a warp
or a bend to one direction
or another.
[David] It's important
to straighten the blade
before you harden it.
[J] Dave, what are you doing?
Dave!
Ah, he's gonna break it.
[David] If I bend it too much,
it could crack.
If the blade cracks,
I'm finished.
So I decided I'm gonna take
the blade to the grinder.
And hopefully,
it will work itself out.
[clinking]
Looks like Mareko's preparation
is paying off.
He's taking that blade
and suddenly, it's a knife.
[Mareko] I got the blade
forged out really fast.
I'm feeling pretty good
about the profile.
Now I could quench the blade.
[Wil] Mareko's in.
The first thing I wanna do
is check it with a file
because I know that's something
they're gonna do.
[swishes]
And it's soft.
I can't submit a soft blade
to the judges.
I have to heat-treat it
a second time.
But I'm a little worried
about running out of time.
[Wil] There we go.
David is in the quench.
And Josh has quenched.
[Jason] Yeah.
[roars]
Not the hair on my arm.
I'd like to say
that's the first time
I've burned the hair off my arm,
but it's happened many times.
[Wil] Three, two, one!
Bladesmiths, drop your tools!
Shut down your machines!
[J] Bladesmiths, welcome
to the Strength Test.
We're gonna have some fun today.
We're gonna take your knives
and strike antler ten times.
-Oh, my [bleep].
-[J] Not only is this gonna test
the strength of the edge
of your knife,
but also the overall durability
of the knife itself.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
-I'm ready too.
-All right.
[Josh] The Antler Test
is something I do at home.
And it's extremely aggressive
on the edge.
So I'm definitely a bit nervous.
[knife whacking]
-[giggles]
-Damn!
[serious music]
Well, Josh, we kinda have
a muscle of serration
in the middle now.
It felt good swinging.
-[J] But that edge damage...
-[Josh] Mm-hmm.
-...is concerning.
-[Josh] Yeah.
[Josh] There's a lot of edge
deformation in my blade.
I'm pretty much figured I'm
finished in this competition.
[J] Mareko, you ready?
I'm so excited.
[all laughing]
You know what, honestly,
that's two of us.
[chuckling]
[serious music]
[suspenseful music]
[knife whacking]
Looks a lot better than mine.
[David] It's good, man.
It didn't break.
Well, Mareko,
for the size of this knife,
it's one of the lightest knives
I've ever swung.
You got deformation.
-Got a couple little pieces out.
-[Mareko] Yeah.
But it bit
into the antler really well.
-[Mareko] Cool.
-And it held together.
-[J] Good job.
-Thanks.
[J] David, you're up next.
-You ready?
-I'm ready.
[serious music]
[rock music plays]
[knife whacking]
[serious music]
Nice job.
David, you have a significant
bend in this blade
after the testing.
[J] We got some chipping,
some damage.
Right in that center spot there.
-But it survived. Good job.
-All right. Thanks.
[Jason] We're gonna test
the sharpness of your blades
by maybe cutting
through all these apples.
It will depend on your knife.
If it's sharp enough,
we should have a clean cut
all the way through.
-Josh, are you ready?
-[Josh] I'm ready.
[suspenseful music]
[swishes]
Oh, nice. All right, brother.
Good job.
Thanks.
[sniffles]
Well, Josh, despite your edge
having chipping and wrinkling
from the antler damage,
it's still sharp enough
to cut through the apples.
-[Jason] Well done.
-Thank you.
[Jason] Mareko, you ready?
-Yeah, man.
-All right.
[suspenseful music]
[swishes]
[David] Nice job. Nice job.
-Nice work.
-All right, man.
Mareko, it went through
like a lightsaber, man.
[imitating lightsaber whoosh]
It just zipped right through
like they weren't even there.
-[Mareko] Thanks.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
-[Jason] David.
-You ready?
-Hai.
All right, let's do it.
[David] My knife is definitely
more of an apple slicer.
Jason is going to cut
through the apples, I'm sure.
[suspenseful music]
[swishes]
[tense music]
David, during
the Antler Testing, it has bent.
[Jason] The bend
is actually curving up.
And if I'm lying down like this,
it's accentuated.
So as I'm trying to travel down,
it's very difficult
to accurately slice
through those apples.
Well, this is the Olympics
of knife-making, right?
I'll take a bronze any day.
-[Jason] That's right.
-[laughter]
For that, David, I commend you
and I respect you very much.
Thank you very much.
David, as you acknowledged,
this time, the judges' decision
is an easy one.
And I have to ask you
to please the Forge.
Thank you, guys.
I'm feeling a little sad.
[David]
Although I'm not ashamed.
I proved to myself
that I could make a knife again.
I know that people have had
much more difficult times
in their life than I have.
But I would tell anyone
who had a setback in life
to get up, shake it off,
and start again.